trolls fans are you ready for the third
installment trolls banded together will
hit theaters on November 17th and we've
got everything you need to know from the
star studded cast to the brand new
soundtrack and that highly anticipated
NSYNC reunion every trolls movie has a
seriously impressive cast and for the
third installment this already star
studded group is getting even more
exciting rapper kid Cy is Clay got the
drip NSYNC member and actor Joey faton
is a blaze singer songwriter Troy Savon
is Floyd comedian and actor Eric Andre
is John Dory actor and musician Davi
Diggs joins the cast as Spruce oh sorry
AET William it's a wild ride where it
has so many different twists and turns
singer songwriter Camila Cabo joins the
cast oh my gosh hello my name is vaa